Fiona John talked about family what's he
like as a dad oh the boys adore him he's
just a big softy I was 49 when Fiona
have first boy but now it's really sweet
to see them you know they're 23 and 24
Jack and Tommy and they they both sing
play guitar
they both write songs what's that like
for you to watch that it's really great
you can't force somebody to play insane
you know yeah they both picked up the
guitar and just started playing
they'd watched it for so long I never
been able to teach anybody to play the
guitar I just figured a lot of people
learn to play the guitar because they
figured when they see me do it they
favor if he can do it well and a lot of
people pick up the guitar to play your
songs to their kids people who pass my
songs on because they feel like they
weren't singing for their kids and the
kids grow up with them and they're
coming to my shows and now the grandkids
are coming to my shows and they tell me
that they grew up their household always
had one or two of my songs being either
son or played the record yeah it's a
good if there's an honest way to make
this lemon it's a good honest way to
make it yeah